Chad was there ever a time when you said
no to television work yes there was a
time you know when I first got here
there we had a pager and I had to pull
over to my you know call my agent on the
phone and find a payphone and it's just
back in those days usually it was like
if you were a movie actor you were a
movie actor and if you were a TV actor
you were a TV actor and there really
wasn't any in-between and there was a
time when again I was very very young
and I thought well no I don't I don't
want to do television I don't I don't
want to do television I was getting
handed a serious you know I now I'm like
of course I want to do television you
know some of the greatest stuff you can
see right now is on TV but now with
actors you can do there are so many
mediums with social media you know you
got YouTube stars you got vine stars you
got all these different people now but
back when I started it was there was no
internet you know it was movies and TV
and I've been really grateful to to be
able to flow back and forth and do film
and do television I think I've been on
just about every show that's ever come
out which is cool and I you know I feel
blessed to have be able to do both but
there was a time when I was young when I
thought maybe I didn't want to do TV and
I just want to do a movies and that's
that's ignorant thinking no I'm thinking
okay and so if you were to hear suppose
you were with a group of actors who were
maybe early 20s and and you heard them
say that I'm not I just only want to do
this medium not that would you say
anything or would you just kind of let
them develop their own process no I'd
say something we'll say say you're an
idiot
just be honest and say don't be an idiot
you know you know and I have come across
actors that say oh I don't want to do
this right guy you know I got a don't
let me here don't let me hear you
complain about working or about being in
this business we are lucky to be in this
business
to be working and nothing irritates me
more than when I hear other actors
bitching about their work and being on
set and bitching about this and bitching
about that shut your mouth and work you
know um you know if you want a
take it I'll swear and do that but don't
bring it to set because we are very
lucky to do what we do and granted there
have been times when I was much younger
that I didn't realize what I had you
know and I didn't have many older actors
saying to me hey you know shape up it's
not going to be like this you know what
I mean and you know it changed it
changed now I'm so grateful to to work
no matter what it is TV thumb I mean you
know something off the internet I you
know so I would say hey why is it up
wise up and and be appreciative of the
work because most likely your
opportunity is not going to be here
tomorrow
you